puis-je oublier ce coin de paradis
ce petit bout de peau tout vit encore
pour m'encourager
[Musique]
comme la de l'aude en vin et que tu
martin s'était kraft on joue des
précédentes on se trouve le chemin
et on a du chagrin on s'est ajouté
teindra monde des vagues
tu as du mal
acheter des tableaux et des vaches en
photo c'est tout ce que tu as trouvé
ap
nous les intégrons des mets pas ma
chance on le croyait bizarre
un peu patriota fruitema réflexion mais
touchera personnes
si vos pas de reste à tout jamais dans
ma région c'est pire
sur nous
démission je m en mourir pour le
meilleur et pour le pire et si je monte
au ciel
aura peut-être joël il y avait jérémy
reymond conflit de travail
dans un autre pays
j'aimais bien
j'ai des amis
les connais
d
les yeux non
moi demain
nous 17
ces données
derrière ces puits
[Musique]
pour lui
mais ces jeux
belle gueule
des blindés
j'adore
on les sent
la mise
les gars
[Musique]
ce sens
justin est rejetée
soyez sûr j'en suis fois j'ai l'accord
en catégorie d'être avec vous ce soir
qui pétillent
l'émissaire noir
on a les yeux qui brillent
b
[Musique]
juste dire jours soyez sûr j'en suis
fier je la corrèze en cathédrale
avec vous ce soir j
keep it
mini c'est leur droit
les yeux qui brillent
[Musique]
bah
c'est bon c'est bon